mit der perfekten mischung aus fett und
kohlenhydraten macht sebastian lege
stapel chips die absolut unwiderstehlich
sind stapel chips genialer trick der
industrie oder lecker und ein bisschen
kartoffel tolle gewürze fängt einmal an
weil hört nicht mehr auf was macht uns
so gierig auf diesen kleinen knackigen
snack schon im design sind stapel chips
wahre meisterwerke der verführung
anatomisch perfekt geformt um zunge und
gaumen zu schmeicheln alle genau gleich
groß und zwar exakt so groß wie es der
durchschnitts mund verlangt und noch
etwas ist anders als bei normalen
kartoffelchips die zutaten
[Musik]
und jetzt meine ich zumindest zu wissen
was er rein kommt jedenfalls keine
kartoffelscheiben sondern
standardisierte industrierohstoffe wie
reis mehl stärke und kartoffel flocken
gefriergetrocknet das alles zu einem
homogenen teig vermerkt so ist es
möglich unabhängig von der
kartoffelernte immer genau gleich
schmecken wird chips herzustellen
mehr noch durch die zutaten im teig
können die hersteller genau bestimmen
wie braun wie knusprig wie aromatisch
das produkt wird und ihm wie hier mit
einem maßgeschneiderten werkzeug die
perfekte form geben wie man sehen kann
unser stapel chip hat so ungefähr schon
die form aber es fehlt ja noch diese
kleinen charmanten flügelchen die sich
so richtig schön um unsere zunge legen
dafür habe ich mir figge form gebastelt
global über global ich hoffe mal das
ganze wasser was für den teig
eingearbeitet haben wird jetzt raus
gebacken und unser stapel chip wird so
richtig schön kross france heist krachig
produktentwickler wissen wie sehr das
geräusch zum genuss beiträgt da haben
chips kunden klare vorstellungen und
kracht legistik breslin wie ein
richtiger kartoffel
[Musik]
das heißt
die spannung steigt
und na bitte in der free tierform steckt
ein gut gebräunter appetitlicher
kartoffelchips paprikapulver drauf und
dann ab damit zur qualitätskontrolle
[Musik]
es kracht es hat funktioniert
knusprig rund lecker man kann nicht mehr
damit aufhören das aroma die anatomisch
optimierte form und das knusprige
krachen sind wichtige gründe dafür dass
chips essen regelrecht süchtig macht
aber der grundlegende geheime
suchtfaktor liegt woanders
[Musik]
wissenschaftler der uni erlangen
nürnberg sind genau dieser frage
nachgegangen eher durch zufall stellten
sie fest auch laborratten essen gerne
tipps damit war der forschergeist von dr
andreas hess und seinen kollegen geweckt
die wissenschaftler wollten wissen
erliegen auch die schlauen ratten der
verführung durch kartoffelchips
dabei machten sie die entscheidende
entdeckung immer wenn chips zu 35
prozent aus fett bestehen und zu 55
prozent aus kohlenhydraten verfallen die
ratten in einen regelrechten rausch
wir haben herausgefunden dass die raten
genau die mischung von fett und
kohlenhydrate präferieren was wir in den
chips wunder lebensmittelindustrie auch
drin haben 34 prozent fett 55 prozent
kohlenhydrate
allein diese nährstoffzusammensetzung
ist im laborexperiment verantwortlich
dafür dass die tiere am liebsten chips
fressen
der geschmack spielt offenbar eine
untergeordnete rolle
[Musik]
messungen im computertomographen zeigen
dass der industrielle idealen mix im
rappen gehirn ein wahres feuerwerk
auslöst und die auswirkungen aufs
verhalten kann drs genau beobachten sind
chips in der nähe handeln die tiere wie
ferngesteuert sie fressen ungehemmt bis
der letzte krümel verputzt ist und wir
kennen das letztendlich von uns auch wir
stehen abends nach dem abendessen auf
sind einig gesättigt wir gehen an den
fernseher eröffnen die tüte chips der
film ist aus und wie ein wunder passiert
es dass die chipstüte auch leer
gefuttert ist ist die 35 55 formel eine
geheimwaffe der lebensmittelindustrie um
uns hemmungslos zu machen
die forscher wiederholten ihre messungen
mit menschlichen probanden chips essen
im dienst der wissenschaft und dann ab
in die röhre
tatsächlich auch beim menschen lösen
chips unmittelbar etwas im gehirn aus
die aufmerksamkeit steigt zentren für
belohnungen und suchtverhalten werden
aktiv ein relikt der evolution für
urmenschen war es sinnvoll bei
nahrhaftem essen mal richtig maßlos
reinzuhauen denn meist gab es nur karge
kost
heute im überfluss von fett und
kohlenhydraten schadet diese presse auf
automatik viel mehr als sie nutzt doch
wir verhalten uns wie dressiert schon
das bild von chips lässt uns das wasser
im mund zusammenlaufen
das ist das eigentliche was so ein
bisschen dahinter steht dass wir
aufgrund dieser nahrungsmittel für
anlass werden mehr zu essen als unser
normales empfinden eigentlich und
vorgeben würde
und das birgt potenziell immer
gesundheitliche risiken
ob das tiefkühlpizza oder eis überall
findet sich die magische formel 35
prozent fett 55 prozent kohlenhydrate
sicherlich keine pisa erfindung der
industrie sondern einst ein cleverer
trick der natur der sich aber heute
leicht zum geldverdienen ausnutzen lässt
[Musik]
was sind eure lieblings chips sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips